what happens when the zombie apocalypse
reaches the highest levels of government
check out this story we got from
post-millennial
u.s navy in shambles as leaders
prioritize wokeness
over combat readiness this is a report
that was commissioned by congress and
they found
in in a couple instances one there was
on the on the uss
bonham richards i think it's called it's
a 750 million dollar warship
started on fire why they said the people
there weren't properly trained
but i can tell you what they were
properly trained on diversity
they have begun to prioritize diversity
trainings over combat readiness
one person testified that they handed a
cd to someone said here's your combat
training go go do it
but don't forget to finish your
diversity training no joke
so now you have the zombie apocalypse
we're in a zombie apocalypse people
don't realize this
did you think the zombies were going to
be like walking around mindlessly just
groaning and
and muttering nonsense i hope you did
because that's literally what's
happening with these people that's what
they're doing
and then what happens is they show up
they all start screaming
and the person goes and then turns into
one of them
yeah right now now the navy is they're
looking at their phones
and that's turning them into zombies
soon they'll be in the neural net
and then they'll just be like full on
like getting the information they'll be
you'll be looking at you in the eyes but
they'll be thinking about the donald
trump video they're watching in their
mind
yeah it's the borg dude the problem you
know what's funny about the borg and
star trek
is that it was efficient you know it was
able to work as a collective and get the
job done
what they don't realize is that who
knows which idea
or or or ideology will become dominant
within the collective
so you right we we right now have this
this you know assimilator die
mentality among the woke left they're
just
cultist ideologues who believe nonsense
and that's why the critical race theory
thing is so weird because
it keeps changing the left wokeness it's
amorphous there's no rules it makes no
sense they're just
insane people they're they they cancel
each other one day wemmickson
is the right word the next day it's the
wrong word like oh wymixon is inclusive
the next day oh it's offensive because
trans women are women you can't say
whimixon
there's no rules then one day they say
asian people are white adjacent
stop defending them the next day stop
asian hate they are just
it's just it's just a zombie horde the
only thing the collective strives to do
is protect the collective at all costs
so that means it will not necessarily
provide any meaningful function
to the the the body at large other than
minimize damage to itself so when it
gets into the navy and it's destroying
things and and things just fall apart
that doesn't matter the navy failing and
these ships falling apart
the u.s surrendered to iran because of
this that's what the report said
did you know you guys know that 2019 the
u.s surrendered and american soldiers
are on their knees with their hands on
their heads as iranian revolutionary
guard come in
at guns and point them at our soldiers
why because they weren't prepared for
combat and that was under trump
trump didn't realize what was going on
and he should have he had he had people
like mark
milly who was dumb as a box of rocks who
was part of the zombie horde
the whole system is just a flame that's
it it's just it's just
man you know what i'll say the night is
always darkest before the dawn but
here's the way i see it
there is a a an insulated bubble that is
the community that we have and the
people we talk to and the people who
watch this show and the people who share
this show and go to timcast.com become
members
these people are prepared more so paying
attention
active and principled for the most part
there are hate watchers i'm sure
but if the system screws up you know you
look at what michael mals says about
peaceful divorce the dissolution of the
united states
if that were to happen i'm not worried
at all i mean
yeah i got some chickens we got some
garden food we're going we we've got
supplies we've got resources
i'll figure it out i would honestly love
that i love michael malus so yeah he's
he's a smart fella huh
so if look if there was a collapse
the fires rage so hot within the federal
government it just falls apart no real
civil war just
yeah i think everybody's standard of
living would go down i think
i'd be all right with it no it'd be
horrible it'd be horrible no no what i
mean is like
i don't want it to happen you know i
want i want to see america flourish and
be strong and last a thousand
generations because we believe in really
great things but we're being corrupted
from the inside out
so what what would i feel if i woke up
one day and they're like
america's no more i'd be like all right
let's start planting food let's
you know i've got survival guides and
stuff i'll look up proper crop rotation
and
standard farming practices i'll go to
the community up on the mountain and say
guys what do you propose we do shall we
start you know working together and
and you know figuring out things on our
on our own look man
i think at the end i think if you look
at people who live in rural areas
they know how to deal with storms they
know how to deal with trees falling down
in power going out tornado they know how
to deal with running out of toilet paper
the people in cities don't the problem i
was studying um kings in general's
youtube channel highly recommend go
there
amazing documentary channel and i was
watching a documentary on the fall the
roman
empire last night what happened oh well
firstly it was barbarians attacked
the empire shattered into like six
different countries
the front the jerk the gauls basically
the people from the north came down and
took
took over all of rome destroyed it and
created the italian empire or the
italian country and then over like 150
years they stripped the rights of the
romans away
slowly so if if we were to do a peaceful
divorce here i could see like yeah
you've got your farm
but then all of a sudden in 30 years or
40 years they come in and take a third
of your property
and and you're at at their at their whim
because they have the weapons they have
the government and then 50 years later
they take another
half of your property and then all of a
sudden they they draft your kids into
slavery
and so if we lose this government
we're at risk of of suffering something
like that i think okay so right now our
government really super freaking sucks
and i would not be sad to see that go
you know
i don't feel like we would miss it all
the red tape would be gone all the
restrictions on these weapons that we
were
guaranteed in the constitution would be
gone you'd be able to
you know do it shall not be in france
exactly but apparently you can't
it's very difficult it used to be when
they talked about dissolving the u.s
people would raise the issue of the
military they're like what'll happen
with the military as far as i'm
concerned the military is
off the table now the navy can't even
defend against iranian soldiers
two years ago are you serious and and
tom cotton is talking about
he has no confidence that the us
military will be able to go up against
china
china freaking cares about their
military they're taking this seriously
we're not they can see it mark milley is
a horrible sign of that and i
i'm i feel like a dissolution of the
union would be preferable to this
knowledge
china's not worried about the diversity
so maybe
they are that's why they banned all the
lgbt accounts on wechat
oh right yeah overnight we don't want
that diversity stuff in china
you guys know about john teeter tighter
or what was it teeter
no that name sounds familiar yeah it
does something it's a it's probably a
hoax
it was an old early internet thing where
this guy claimed to be from the future
oh yeah and there was some really
interesting things about what he was
saying
and a lot of people were like wow the
things this person is saying
sounds like you know they're a really
smart person at the very least someone
was like this has got to be like an mit
engineer
who has access to like serious academic
records to pull off this hoax
or a team of people or maybe he was
really a time traveler
that's more like well it doesn't really
matter it's probably a hoax because i
mean
you know look what's what's the easiest
solution someone when the internet lied
hey that happens all the time
but anyway i bring it up just because uh
when this was going on i think was like
the late 90s early 2000s john teeter was
posting on forums claiming that the u.s
was going to fall apart in the
in the like early aughts or whatever and
said like canada would take the northern
midwest areas
the east coast would join europe the
west coast would join china and the
southern states would go to like mexico
or whatever
and uh starting to seem more and more
plausible
isn't it i gotta get off the east coast
yeah but to your point i think that
would be cool if we like balkanized
whatever like i grew up like hunting
fishing shooting i know how to do all
that i could survive i think
wrestling perfect got the self-defense
going on i think i'd be
like a grizzly bear yeah you know one
problem i could
one problem with the balkans is it's
been basically the
the butt of military ravage for like
2 000 years i mean that that area of the
world because it's splintered been
splintered for so long it's just
constantly overrun conquered people are
murdered
genocide i mean just tr tragedy in the
balkans so
because they don't have a strong unified
force um
there were periods where they did like
the byzantine empire but it's kind of
sad
you know so i we the power of our states
yeah the federal government is so
important because if we didn't have
coordinated military between states we
would just be picked apart let's do this
this roman stuff man it's freaky i know
like the parallels to the roman empire
so how would you so would you support a
very
decentralized federal government that
you know
bare bones it protects your rights it
protects you know our nation's security
but you know the states are kind of
separate do what they want oh yeah i'd
love to build an app where you could
vote on local issues like a tinder style
app where you could be like
hey everyone i'm this is ian crossland i
want to put a fountain on main street
it's going to cost 40 000
vote for this project terrible idea you
go through and then if you like that you
can swipe right add it to your list of
things you want to put your tax dollars
for life that wouldn't be happening
terrible a terrible idea i don't think
so yeah absolutely decentralized and
localized governance basically during
occupy wall street i don't know about
i don't know about the app portion of it
during occupy wall street when someone
goes
i think we should we should get bins for
the sanitation crew then someone was
like that's a good idea i'm going to
propose that our bins
are fair trade and then someone was like
yeah but they got to be recycled too and
they went
okay so we all agree fair trade recycled
bins go find them it was ridiculous
the stupidest thing you could find those
they didn't they did they went to
walmart
they were like everyone agreed and then
they went to the store so we can't find
it just by the way
so if i if they were like vote for this
fountain and everyone was like yeah and
they put all this money towards it and
they didn't know how to build the
fountain that's a problem so you know
you would have to like be able to follow
through with your plan i'll tell you
exactly what happened
i've learned the wonders of septic leech
fields only in the past
year because i never had a septic system
before but i can tell you exactly what
will happen
when a bunch of people who know nothing
about anything show up and they go hey
look a big empty field
i propose we build a building on it i
vote everyone goes yay we vote and then
the one that comes up guys guys guys
that's the leech field for the thousand
gallon septic tank
you can't build on and they go we voted
we passed the resolution
out of our way and then they build on a
septic leech field and
then they die although i don't i mean
that's why you have governors
you have governors and mayors to to like
stop stupid
behavior you know but so you mean
elected representatives yeah
rather than like rely on an external
person to come build that building for
you you could
like locally here's what would happen
dude people would vote for the building
then someone would say
look that's a leech field we have a
regulation barring the building of that
and someone go i propose we get rid of
that regulation
ah they also they'll vote to get rid of
it because people want to make money
and it's a it's it's it's it but it's
not easy to govern so
democracy does not work if a bunch of
people voted for the the building on the
leech field and it was all these people
voted for it so it was ready to go
and then all of a sudden they found out
it can't happen it would be removed from
your list by who
by by the government by the governor
basically yeah by the government so the
government or whoever that means at any
point the mayor could be like
i do not want this civil rights bill
deleted i'm the smart one
well if it violated some sort of
standard yeah what standard by who who
sets the standard the leech field
who sets the standard well the people do
through the governance right so when the
mayor says you can't bother the leech
field like i said they'll go we vote to
say you can
so the mayor is pointless at that point
um but i'm not saying direct democracy
over
rule things i'm just saying a way for us
to pool funds locally
yeah do you ever look at a uh a map of
a topographical map of manhattan you can
actually see in the skyscrapers where
the bedrock is it's fascinating
what do you mean they can only build the
skyscrapers on bedrock wow
they can't build it on the dirt it sinks
that's why there's a lot of cities where
you're like i wonder why i don't build
skyscrapers here brought to swamp
like dc is a swamp yeah you know what i
mean like literally swamp
so it's hard to build massive buildings
because they sink
manhattan is a big rock so that they can
build and they can carve holes and do
subways it's actually
you know fairly easy but there's like a
line because there are some areas that
are you know dirt and mud and stuff
regular people don't know these things
so they're like i propose we build a
building sideways
and then you're like that you can't we
shouldn't do that i'm gonna do it anyway
and everyone's like yay sideways
building woohoo
and then construction crew goes hey
we're getting paids
going to go builds the sidesways
building and then they start building it
and then they just
no no you definitely need checks and
balances but i can't stand that like
people in upper echelons of government
are deciding what gets built where and i
don't have like
an opportunity to input yeah like a
convenient way to input
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you